greetings everyone this is rob
sanders from simply learn and today
we're going to talk about
how to get traffic to your website so
thank you for joining and let's get
started
before i tell you how to bring traffic
to your website let me tell you
why this is so important okay why do we
want to bring users to our website
i mean it has to be on equal ground as
web development and design
is somebody who goes to your site and
then does something when they get to
your site so you have users
and when those users get to your site
they're generating
page views and traffic and you want to
turn that traffic
into engagement okay so each page's
traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so
when you go when somebody goes to your
website they look at a page that's a
page view
in certain pages on your website you
want to turn that page view into a
conversion okay whether that be
you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website
but first we need to get the visitors to
your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate
sales which means revenue or you can
increase brand awareness
or you can earn revenue through
sponsored posts
and advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad
you're gonna earn a percentage of that
click okay what that click is worth
so having a website means a lot of good
things for you
but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do
is we're going to tell you how to drive
traffic to your website so there's lots
of different ways
in which you can bring traffic to your
website well the first is paid
advertising
so paying to advertise your products
services with ads is one of the easiest
ways
to drive traffic to your website so some
of the options available
are search ads social media ads or
display ads
so search ads are ads that are displayed
in the search
engine results so when a user types in a
keyword
query you want your ad to show up based
on that keyword query
okay so an example is digital marketing
course somebody types in digital
marketing course and simply learn
is the first app that shows up how do we
know it's an ad because
you can see the word ad next to the
domain
so when somebody clicks on that link
simply learn is going to pay
google so that's how search advertising
works
okay the next is social so social media
marketing involves
increasing traffic or engagement or
brand awareness and lots of different
strategies
but you're instead of doing this on
search you're doing it on a social media
platform
okay so for example you can advertise on
any particular platform
and the way you advertise could be with
an image it could be with a video
so in this case you could see cobreo
is doing a sponsored ad here how to
succeed with google ads
and then another form of advertising is
display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites
so with display unlike search you have a
choice
in the ad format with search you only
have text ads
but with display you have text edge
image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options
in which you can advertise on other
websites
so the idea here is to get your ad
in front of the right audience when they
could see your display banner your
banner ad
then it's going to be more visual more
appealing
generate some brand interest and
hopefully you can get somebody
to click on that ad and over to your
website so
that's paid advertising again through
search through social through display
but
you can also promote your site on social
media so once your content has gone live
you could take advantage of different
social media platforms i mean it really
depends
on what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform
so facebook is best suited for
industries like food and beverages and
news and media
and if you're selling a product so you
fall into one of those categories and
facebook could be the right platform for
you
if you're involved in again beauty or
food and beverage or e-commerce then you
can also
leverage instagram which is part of
facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on facebook
you can also advertise on instagram and
or instagram so it doesn't have to be
and facebook and instagram it could be
facebook or instagram
you also have linkedin as a platform
linkedin is great for b2b
so if you're trying to promote industry
news or or
tips and best practices or job postings
then linkedin is the place for you it's
a b2b platform
it's great for targeting specific
industries targeting specific job levels
or job descriptions okay so linkedin
is great if you're into b2b focusing on
the business side of it
so you also have youtube now youtube is
part of google's ecosystem
youtube is a video platform okay so
it's great if you're trying to promote
gaming or entertainment if you're a
vlogger
okay so youtube's a great way to promote
your site
uh by getting your product out there in
the form of a video
and then you have twitter twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
industries
beauty and fitness news and media
entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but
a lot of people are active on twitter
and it's a great way to generate some
awareness and get some clicks over to
your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there
the third way in which you can drive
traffic to your site is guest
blogging so most of you already know
what blogging is all about
well if you're blogging for your own
site you can jump on somebody else's
site
and blog on their behalf so having the
opportunity to guest
post on another website can be very
helpful because one
that other blog could have lots of
traffic and have a a well-known brand so
if you're
blogging on another blog it's going to
build your brand awareness
and potentially increase traffic to your
blog or website
so it exposes to you to targeted traffic
so if you're going to guest blog guest
blog on a site that's very
relevant to your business or industry
that way you're targeting the right
audience
okay you can expand your personal
network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience
and then obviously for service because
it generates a backlink so serps
search engine ranking pages means that
hey
if you want to rank organically you're
going to have to generate
some backlinks so guest blogging is a
way to generate some backlinks to your
site and an effect
that's going to help you get your pages
ranked higher
because google is going to recognize the
relationship
from one blog to your blog and build up
your relevancy
so some other benefits here to guest
blogging
is you can grow your social media
following because you can then
promote that on social media that you're
guest blogging
okay again you can improve your online
authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that guest blog
if it's a popular blog then it's
going to help your domain and page
authority for seo
and then the end result is going to
improve your backlink score so
a lot of benefits to guest blogging to
me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that
in the form of a blog and the results of
that is going to mean
more brand awareness for you and turning
that traffic
from that other blog into qualified
leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way
an interesting way to generate traffic
to your site so reaching out to
thought leaders for interviews okay
could generate some credibility
for you and the other person so it's
reciprocal so it means that you're
active in the industry that you're in
and it allows you to engage with
other leaders in the industry and the
indirect net result of that could be
increased traffic because if you do the
interview
and you record it or if it's via video
then you can obviously post it on other
platforms
and that could in turn drive traffic to
your website obviously just like
guest blogging it's going to increase
your reach so getting yourself
out there if nobody knows who your brand
is and they know who the thought leaders
are
and they say you're interviewing the
thought leaders then that's going to put
you in front of these people
and so it's going to increase your reach
another way
to drive traffic to your website is just
to make sure your website's responsive
and what do we mean by response of well
we mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides
shows shrinks enlarges or moves content
so that it conforms to the browser
that that person's looking at on your
web for your website
so if somebody's looking on mobile at
your website you want to make sure that
your website adjusts accordingly
so you want to be able to you know test
to make sure it's responsive
and so is content arranged based on
importance
okay does it work across different
browsers on different devices
and do the images text and everything
else align
just like it does on desktop so there
are plenty of tools out there on the web
all you need to do is just do a search
for you know check my website for
responsiveness
you know so you you can use plenty of
tools to check
to see if your website is responsive
towards multiple devices
why is that important because if
somebody goes to your website via mobile
and your site doesn't align properly or
the content's all stretched out
and somebody has to maneuver their
browser just to see your website
then chances are they're not going to
come back chances are they're not going
to convert
okay so you want to be able to revise
your device browser combinations you
want to make sure that everything works
accordingly
you want to be able to test those fonts
make sure they look good
and then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate
so if they're on mobile are they going
to navigate just as easy as they can on
desktop
and if you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed
so that way when somebody's looking at
your website they're not getting
interfered with
on mobile and then of course you want to
make sure that these pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop
as they should on mobile and vice versa
so this should not
take a long time to load so moving on
from responsiveness on mobile to
building a brand community so brand
community refers to a group of people
who identify your brand
and use your brand as a platform to
exchange ideas and contribute content
some advantages of having a brand
community are
promoting brand evangelism and loyalty
it can be a source of feedback loyalty
and ideas
so build a community build a brand
community
who you know identify with you okay so
continue to
you know treat these people as loyal
customers
okay maybe give them a promotion uh to
use specifically just for them that they
can use on your website
or talk directly to them because you
know that they're
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times
so talk to them differently as well you
know who these people are
and that's what building a brand is all
about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand
and messaging and talking to them as if
they're part of your own
community your own family so you can use
user generated content that provides
future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
community could be in turn used
to promote or used in future marketing
strategies
i.e advertising i.e post on social
okay it can also provide pr
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on
the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is
should be able to identify with your
audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually
going to become part of a community
these are
group of people who identify with you
what you're trying to sell
what your cause is what your mission
statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately
give them the what they deserve the
respect and loyalty that they deserve as
well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so
the next thing you could do to drive
traffic is be active in the comment
section
so engage in relevant and
thought-provoking conversations on other
blogs
and sites it doesn't necessarily have to
be another blog per se it could be
other sites like reddit or quora or
media
sites that have a lot of content that
are broken out by industry
that allow you to engage in conversation
that allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay
so be active because when you're active
people are gonna see that hey you're a
leader in the industry you know what
you're talking about
you have some some brand equity you have
some thought
and some knowledge on the specific topic
and subject
so it just puts you in a better light
when you can respond and be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to
search engine optimization also known as
seo or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site
you're going to have to implement an seo
strategy
why do you want to implement an seo
strategy because it can help you improve
your
overall search ability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still
king in terms of volumes of people using
search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found
it also builds trust and credibility
because still a majority of the people
who do a search click on an organic
search listing
and so if you're found organically and
you're ranked number one
then chances are somebody's going to
click
on your listing and it provides
increased engagement and traffic
and so what that means is more traffic
more engagement
an engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a
document or the clicking on the play
button of a video
or or submitting a form or signing up
for a newsletter
or calling these are all forms of
engagement so
the the amount of traffic you drive from
organic
search to your website is only going to
improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
and improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well
if you're getting lots of traffic from
organic search you have a really good
opportunity to do a b testing
and when you do a b testing you can
improve user experience meaning you're
showing one variation against the other
from people coming from organic search
and so
this is helpful and that you know
if you're running an a b test the
variation has a chance to
improve or outperform the original and
if it outperforms the original you're
improving user experience
and then it helps target quality traffic
so seo to me or all search
is the only medium in which you're
meeting somebody halfway you're you're
addressing what they're looking for so
somebody's looking for a pair
of red women's nike shoes
the 2019 model and you have
that particular product to offer well
you have a chance of showing up
via organic search somebody types in new
women's red
nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model
then of course they're going to probably
likely
click on your listing because you have
what they're looking for
and and that goes with any keyword any
industry any business any
segment any type of product you're
selling
so again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here
to meet people halfway to drive quality
traffic
to get them to enjoy a good user
experience all the while
generating engagement and along with seo
we want to be able to build backlinks so
seo is a two pronged approach meaning
you have two strategies in one on page
and off page
and so off page involves backlinking so
backlinks are just
links that direct users from other
websites to your own website
so with that inherently it's going to
drive traffic
qualified traffic to your website
because if somebody's on a relevant
website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning
they're going to be relevant and so
backlinking because it's an off-page
strategy why is it an off-page seo
strategy because
if google crawls that other site that
has a link to you
then that's going to give you credit
because google say hey the site's
getting some
links from some relevant sites we must
think they're relevant and therefore
we're going to trust this site so by
google
trusting your site it's going to improve
your organic ranking
and with the organic rankings being
improved
meaning it's going to mean faster
indexing
so what does that mean so you want to be
indexed by the search engines
and so the quicker google can find your
pages even if it's on somebody else's
site
then that means they're gonna follow
that link go to that page on your site
and take that page back to their servers
to be indexed okay so the quicker you
can get indexed the quicker you
get found and then it helps with
referral traffic so
again we noticed that our efforts are on
seo
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website
hey that still counts that's referral
traffic okay
so that's a side advantage to having
backlinks
is good traffic from other sites okay so
those
those are inherently the some of the
reasons to do backlinking
okay never hurts i mean there's brand
awareness reasons to being on other
sites as well
there's industry leadership meaning if
you you post content on reddit
okay you're coming across as an industry
leader but yet generating a backlink
which helps with seo and referral
traffic so there's a lot of benefits to
building
backlinks and the opposite of backlinks
are internal links
so you want to do internal linking and
that just means connecting one page on
your site to another
and why is that beneficial because it
can help direct
visitors to other pages they wouldn't
normally otherwise
find via your navigation so if you're
active on a blog
don't be afraid to include multiple
internal links
you want to move people through your
site you want the flow of traffic
to go from one page to another to
another and so when you do internal
linking
just like with backlinks it's going to
improve the indexing of your website
google is going to
follow those links and index those pages
and google does give credit
from an seo perspective from an internal
linking perspective so
if one page is linked to another and
that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that
the other reason we want to do internal
linking again you want to move people
from your one page of your site to the
other
and when you do that it's going to
reduce bounce rates so bounce rate is
simply
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave
so if i have 100 people land on my home
page and only
one person went to another page and the
other 99
left the site then that's a 99
bounce rate so by putting internal links
in place
you're helping people move from one page
to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people
on your site you want to be greedy it
also drives traffic to older posts so
again when we say older posts we're
really referring to blog posts so
if you have a relevant blog post and
you're writing a new blog post
then link the two together if it's
relevant link it i don't you know
regardless of how old it is
you know you want to show google that
these older blog posts just because they
were written a year ago doesn't mean
they're outdated
and old-fashioned okay or useless you
want to keep them alive by linking to
them
so to me that's a good strategy for
internal linking
link to older blog posts you know show
people you're an industry expert you've
been doing this for a while
and then you have lots of content to
share okay so
the longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage
and convert and some other inherent
benefits improves page rank
so what we mean by pagerank is simply
just a rank that google gives pages so
the more internal linking you have
the better off you are and then it helps
spread link juice
across websites and won't mean be by
link juice again just like backlinking
it builds relevancy so just keep all
these inherent benefits in mind to
internal linking
the end result is keeping the flow of
traffic on your site
and all these other benefits will fall
into place okay
so another way in which you can really
hone in on traffic to your website is
long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so
they're usually three or longer keywords
in a phrase
okay so long tail keywords really
nowadays account for most web searches
people
really take the time to even post
questions as a search query say
likely somebody it's unlikely somebody's
going to go into search and just type in
the word shoes
they might type in red shoes but that's
unlikely
what they're probably going to type in
is you know red
nike running shoes 2019
or some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword
and some of the advantages of using long
tail keywords to be found for are
less competition so if you're using
broad keywords like red shoes
then who doesn't want to be found for
red shoes well you don't necessarily
you don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
red shoes
it could be running shoes it could be
work shoes it could be
you know boots it could be slippers okay
it's too bright
so long tail keywords help narrow it in
and the more
narrow and focused the keyword is the
less competition it's gonna have
and when something's not competitive in
the form of a keyword
then that means your chances of ranking
for that keyword are going to be greater
and the chance of you ranking faster are
going to be greater and then of course
if somebody's looking for exactly what
you have to offer
then you have a higher chance to convert
that person so if you have exactly those
2019
red nike women's running shoes and
somebody does a search for that and
that's a long tail keyword and they
click on your organic listing
if you have the right price then they're
probably going to convert
so you have a really good chance of
converting somebody using long tail
keywords
so my point here is if you're looking
for keywords to use
focus on longer tail don't focus on one
or two keyword phrases
what it also does is brings targeted
traffic so even if somebody doesn't
convert hey
they could be back because it's exactly
what they're looking for
and if you're focusing on longer tail
keywords like i just mentioned stay away
from the shorter ones it's just
easier to optimize your page for seo
so remember seo is a two pronged
approach on page and off page
we talked about off page with internal
linking and backlinks
on page is all about making sure those
keywords you choose
are integrated in with the page you want
to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in
so it enables easier on-page
optimization
okay let's switch away from seo to email
marketing
so let's focus on email marketing as a
form
or method of driving traffic to your
website so email marketing has been
around a long
time in terms of digital marketing why
because it provides an effective way to
convert leads into sales
why because you can send personalized
emails to a target audience
so when you send an email to somebody on
a regular basis
you know who that person is so what are
you doing in the email
you're writing a specific message to
that person well email marketing is the
same thing
except you're just sending an email to a
larger group of people
and when you send an email to a larger
group of people
you're still going to personalize the
message right
you're not going to send a generic email
to 1 000 people
okay nobody's going to do that so make
sure your email is targeted and if it's
targeted
it could be cost effective why because
sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people
or a large group of people is going to
be cost effective it's not
cost per click you know it's not cost
per open
okay so email usually depending on the
the
email provider you're using really is a
flat fee so it just really depends on
how many emails you're sending
or how how many people you're sending
the email to
as well so but email generally tends to
be more cost effective than other forms
of marketing
so look at the email content provider
you're using
and just get a sense of what they charge
but if you look at it and do a
comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords
so email marketing is also time saving
okay meaning
it's a one-time thing and done so once
you send the email
it's just a matter of you know watching
and looking at the metrics and learning
what's going on
so you don't make the same mistakes
again but it is time
conducive meaning you send out one email
and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns
and it provides real-time marketing so
when you do send the email
more than likely a majority of the
people on day one or the day you send
the email are going to be able to
view it open it click on some of the
links
and convert so that's normally what
happens in email
majority of the people open it on day
one and it kind of tells off from there
so think about it as real time
so when you send that email and if you
have a thousand people on your email
recipient list break it up send the
first 500
first with a different subject line and
then you can see
the data come in and if you don't see
the good results
from the subject line or the body of the
email or
you know the page you're going to then
make adjustments before you send the
other email to the next 500. so that's a
great thing about emails you can break
up the email
into two groups the first group and then
the second group
with different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of
time apart that way you can learn from
the first email
because with email you are generally
going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email
okay so the other thing about email it's
less intrusive
so normally people who are going to get
the email
are the ones who sign up for the email
so they're almost expecting your email
so when they get your email again as
long as you're not sending an email on a
daily basis
normally most companies send it monthly
or bi-weekly
it's not going to be as intrusive okay
and then it also helps build credibility
increased visibility and brand awareness
meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's
going to show off your credibility
meaning you could put some testimonials
in the email you could put some good
affiliations you can put a good article
to an industry article you just wrote so
email is going to inherently
continue to build brand awareness for
you okay and it's an easy way to track
roi
so if your e-commerce it's pretty clear
you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something
it's easily trackable because you could
track it right from that email
so one thing i want to say there is just
if you do send an email
make sure you're tracking that campaign
and you want to be able to use an
analytics program
like google analytics if you use google
analytics you're going to be able to
track
when you send the email who clicks on it
and who converts so you want to be able
to measure an
roi for these emails and you can and
that's the beauty of email marketing
okay let's move away from email
marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for effective social media
promotion
it's a great way to bring traffic to
your website so
why do we recommend webinars well
because it provides direct
content contact within your target group
what do we mean by contact with your
target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service
so if you have a facebook community you
could do a facebook live event
or you could do a youtube or you know
you can even
set up a webinar on another platform but
promote it on social media
and if you're pronouncing something on
social media you're probably promoting
it to
people who are already following you or
like you and so that's what we mean by
direct contact with your target group so
you're going to be able to create a
webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness
and credibility and the great thing
about webinars is you don't need some
fancy software
i mean i'm talking to you on a webinar
right now and so
webinars are free all you need is a
video
camera and a recorder that's all and
that's all built in with software
so there's plenty of software out there
that allows you just to do a webinar
really quick and easy
there's lots of opportunities in
software so
and a lot of them are very cost
effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money
and webinars again allow you to talk to
your targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients
it helps build credibility and in effect
drive traffic to your website
and when somebody does attend a webinar
they're likely going to be highly
engaged
because you're inviting them they're
going to opt
into the webinar and the great thing
about webinars is even if they don't
attend the webinar the day you have it
it's going to be recorded
so they can always go back and watch it
so whoever watches the webinar is going
to be engaged because it's going to be a
topic they're interested in and then
users are likely to become prospective
customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently
interesting to maybe a larger group of
people
you can promote that on social media and
potentially get prospective customers
to sign up and watch the webinar and if
you do
they're going to be engaged and then
take the next step oh i like what this
guy this person has to say
they seem to be credible i like their
personality i like their brand i like
their product
i'm gonna go check their web out their
website okay so
webinars allow you to kind of pull in
more people as well as just your
community
because you can promote the webinar and
you can promote it in advance
and you can leverage social media for
that okay so something related
to webinars incorporating video content
so videos
have been proven to be a really good way
to attract new visitors
and it just it makes your website very
engaging when you have videos
on your website as well so if you create
video
you have an opportunity to post it on
various video platforms like
youtube or vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or
just embedded in a blog post or embed
it in a facebook post or a tweet okay so
you can do a lot with video and having
video on your site
is going to increase engagement okay
when you increase engagement
good things happen that's going to lead
to increased conversions in sales or
roi or just like we mentioned the
webinar
can help build trust with your audience
even that webinar you could post
on your website so you want people to
engage
by watching this video they watch the
video they're going to gain
trust in you because you're talking
directly to that person that user that
audience
that visitor to your website and when
you get bail trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike
text or imagery videos really do
engage with the audience and so the more
video you could do
the better off you are because again you
can leverage social
to draw attention to your brand and
product and service
and then you can have that video on your
website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves roi
so always think video there's plenty of
video software out there that you can
leverage
and the great thing about video 2 is hey
most people are using mobile phones
these days
smartphones and so video works just as
well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging
regardless of what device somebody uses
and then of course if they're watching
the video on
facebook or youtube then chances are
they're going to
share that particular video which is
going to bode well for your brand
and traffic okay so video if somebody
likes a video it's very easy to share
video
especially from a mobile phone so
youtube just makes it so easy
to share or like or subscribe to a
channel
it just it becomes that much easier
things can go
viral and chances of them going viral
with video are going to be greater
okay so other ways to drive traffic to
your website is submit your content to
content
aggregators so what's a content
aggregator well a content aggregator is
like
reddit that provides a great platform
for you to post your content so that's
what a content aggregator is really a
site like reddit or medium or quora
where you could post content to a large
number of people okay
so with reddit people are either going
to
upvote it or downvote it so the more
upvotes you get or thumbs up
or likes or people who encourage that
content
the more of a chance it has to be found
and so
first thing out of the gate if you do
provide content to a content aggregator
like reddit
make sure it's good quality content
that's interesting and that should be a
case
the case across the board whether it's a
social post or blog post
make sure the content's unique
professional and interesting
and then if you do say put something on
medium or you do put something
on quora and it is professional and
interesting and thought-provoking then
people are going to react to it
and then that again could lead to
traffic but even if it doesn't lead to
traffic
it helps build brand awareness so if you
have content just like videos leverage
it
put the content out there and when you
put content out there
it's only gonna especially if it's good
content but it's gonna put you in a good
light
so don't be afraid to share your content
on the likes of reddit
or medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites
because good things are only going to
happen and again
referral traffic seo brand awareness
conversions so all these are inherent
benefits of
just sharing your content okay and then
finally we want to learn from analytics
okay so what do i mean learning from
analytics so there are plenty of
analytics platforms out there
one of the most popular is google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with google analytics
so i have to do is just go to google
analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and voila they're doing all the
heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic
but they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it google analytics is
hey you could figure out where users are
coming from are they coming from that
email
campaign that i sent out to a thousand
people are they coming from youtube
based on that video i posted or they
coming from reddit based on the content
i just posted there
or they coming from organic search it so
google analytics can help us
understand how much traffic we're
getting from organic search
so to help us measure our seo efforts
and then with google analytics you could
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop
returning user new user by campaign
by page by language by city
by region i mean there's so many ways in
which to segment your audience and
segmenting simply is
breaking up the entire group of people
who come to your website into different
segments
based on what you want to say so
if you want to look at you know females
between the ages of 18 to 24 who come
from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that
information in analytics if that's your
target audience
then you could see how they're
performing okay so and there are a lot
of benefits to google analytics
definitely want to take advantage of
segmenting in google analytics
you could look at your competition so
there's a benchmarking report the great
thing about google analytics you can
also look at content
and how your content is performing when
somebody
lands on your website are they what page
are they spending time on what page are
they engaging
on the most okay what pages have the
highest bounce rate or the lowest time
on page
so you can really determine what pages
work best
and then of course the end result in
analyzing all this data
is you want to be able to fine-tune your
website so take advantage
of the data that google analytics or any
other analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website
you can make adjustments to your website
to improve
user experience okay so
we went over a lot of different ways to
drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately
if you have any questions feel free to
comment below
ask questions we went over a lot of
different ways to drive
traffic so expect some questions you can
also go to simplylearn.com for more
information
so thank you appreciate it and look
forward to seeing you in the future
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here